okay I have a whole theory that like the
church is actually like a homemaker and
like it's actually like a a breeding
ground for hoes and I'll tell you what
I'll tell you why okay because it's like
what they'll do is they'll have these
chastities and I remember being in high
school because I've always been me you
know I've always kind of like thought
the way I do but I was just like a young
Pearl in high school and we had this
Chastity speaker and I was thinking like
basically she went up and she said I got
ran through but then I found God you
know praise God and then the husband was
like and then the husband was like oh
yeah and I I found her after this and
like I was a virgin and I waited and she
and it's oh and I realized I was like
it's always the women who didn't wait
and I'm like oh it's like they're kind
of marketing you can be a hoe and then
find a husband like it's like a
marketing like I don't think they mean
to but I'm like oh it's like that's what
they're marketing to young women and I
remember like wanting to like ask this
question but Catholic School couldn't
handle but you're saying that so and so
then and so then it's like on top of
that the pastors have this reputation
looking for screw in the congregation
right that's like that's like yeah
that's like that's that's a common thing
I guess
it wasn't it was I've heard it I've
heard it I've heard it here I've heard
it in both places but and I'm like why
is there The Stereotype they must do it
a lot right Justin Bieber's like priest
or whatever Pastor came out and I'm like
no wonder they preach forgiveness
because he wants to screw all the hoes
and so what he's saying is he's saying
all of you guys can wait I'm gonna screw
them and add to the bodies and then you
guys can all marry him after I'm done
and that's that's my kind of preacher
and that's why I have this theory that
like a church is really like that's why
that's why the guys will because the
guys will all tell me the girls are
worse in the church and I'm like why
would they be worse because they
basically Market that you can be a hoe
forever and then get a husband at the
end and so then all the hoes go so
you're saying there's a whole show so
it's a whole show yeah yeah yeah it's a
whole show yeah
go ahead
I want to ask everybody have you ever
seen how the women I'm gonna say black
queen because white women don't just
that good
um
am I lying I don't get involved enough I
love woman I ever see the black woman go
to church right and she dresses what how
much cleavage she shows what how much
heals
how the makeup
how she can walk up and wine better
insurance and as she was in a rave I'm
not gonna lie I'm watching drive past a
church going forward
it's Sunday morning
she just called you first no but hey
what I'm saying Sunday morning Sunday
morning I heard it but Sunday morning
you're getting football like you still
got sleep in your eye look you're seeing
a a a herd of of beautiful women
to come back from Brixton must not go
into Brixton from the night before to
get the men and nine times out of ten
those women in church get run through by
the men that are visiting because they
got a habit and the mothers and the
mother and the mothers and the mothers
don't forget the mothers you know
because the mothers yeah will encourage
them to look your best your Sunday Best
in other words
imagine if the pastors came forward okay
imagine if they said okay like because
they're like they'll say they'll say you
can be saved right like the like the
hoes they'll be like hoes come to church
maybe they don't say it like that so
they basically say hoes come to church
because you can be forgiven for
everything imagine if they said men
don't accept that don't you like wait
for the next round of women leave them
right they will what
no you're right you're right that's why
like that's why I've got there aren't a
lot of guys in general walk into any
church at 70 to 80 women but just
imagine if they flipped it and they said
don't accept that for like the same way
they'll tell men and I can't I'm trying
to articulate this right but the same
way they'll tell women like your husband
should be this this this you should be
equally yoked to man of God blah blah
blah blah blah but it's like they don't
say to the men don't date these ran
through girls don't do it you don't
deserve that you deserve better you
should date this this and this like it's
always what the women should expect from
a husband you know what because the men
that go to church have less bloody count
than the women that go to church yeah I
know but no but I think that's why
though because the men that actually
understand female nature they think this
is nonsense it's all the symptoms
you know what we call these women a
doors and we don't know what to do so
you know we've got to make some weight
like men they're really nice they're
Christians that you take them because
nobody else outside church is going to
want them so they might as well take the
ones no I I think they want to keep the
women single in the church because they
have to make money off of them like each
each girl gives how much a week and like
that's that's the thing and it's kind of
like it's weird because they ask for
donations but when there's more single
homeless women over the age of like
that's the fastest growing homeless
population single women and so if
they're if they're giving like a hundred
bucks a week let's say that's 400 a
month times up by a year that that's a
retirement account go ahead similar I
don't want to say it similar to a club
environment the more attractive women
you attracted
willing with the hand open mental table
but who's is
right so the men are gonna come and
spend their money the most in the
charity books like when you're young
when you're young yeah it's like you're
not necessarily just going to your local
church you're going to the popular
church the church that's popping yeah
that's got that young good looking
environment that's the one you're going
and you're going there in your best
you're waking up early Sunday morning in
your drip like what yo but even in the
church like I remember being in and I've
always been a mess I've always had these
thoughts but I remember being like
younger and they would say make a list
of the things you want in your future
husband and I'm like why don't they say
that to the men make a list of what you
want in your future wife but the problem
is none of the girls in the congregation
can meet that hmm
so basically all these women just go
into church to find the good guys
because they're tired of all the bad
boys I think I think that's that's like
the common response but a lot of times
the girls go and and this is I I hear it
from from guys that it's 28 29 30 right
when time's running out is when they
tend to go to church and if they do get
to church young they leave right when
they get to college and so it's like but
that's your choice
I'm not talking about my church I'm
talking about General feedback I
wouldn't even say I'm crazy religious
but I'm saying that's General feedback
I've just gotten from men they're
experience like different churches same
experience
wow those are my churches because I've
seen so many churches with young people
I don't know I didn't see the evidence
who said their church at night
someone from your church a girl is
busting up with a man right now from
your church because human beings
you're gonna go to church she listen
didn't you say they're going to church
to get husband and all that but looks
that's something
that's not the reason the Lord
you could do that for your yard you
could do that I don't but no you know
people not everyone believes that I'm
not I'm not gonna say are you on the
topic of going to church and making it
all about like relationships and stuff I
when I went to church I recently found
God properly and started going church
and stuff and it had nothing to do with
no man no relationship it was because I
was dealing with my own internal traumas
and God was my backbone God was my safe
place so I wanted to explore what type
of trauma was it was it the no ft no it
wasn't I don't know what that is um
not ft no comments
my last point and then I stopped is that
I feel like for me it's because I've had
it emotional trauma I was learning more
about God at home and I wanted to go to
church more because I wanted to learn
more from people who have spent years
studying it preaching it mastering it
that sort of stuff so my point is I'm
just saying it ain't always about this
sexualization or of women going to
church have a back of bad relationships
because not not every woman is doing
that you might you might not say it it's
not all women I I agree with you it's
just funny when women always seem to
come after a whole phase that's just
what I've heard from the men it's just
it's just interesting how right after
the whole phase now you're here
fascinating I went to church when I when
I was younger and my dad's made me go
and I went and I had a good time and
then as I got older I kind of dropped it
out and I went for a time in my life in
2013 and um I feel like a lot of people
speak to God when their balls deep in
the [__] or when they when they need a
bit of guidance or I need a bit of help
not like oh God you know I'm doing good
and XYZ I feel like back then I looked
so good to help me in a situation and
God told me that the outcome that I
wanted to happen ain't gonna happen and
guess what it never happened good was
right and from then I said you know what
there was someone up there I'm not crazy
so I am a Christian and from a young age
my stepdad wanted me my dad wanted me to
be a Christian but I feel like I find
that space Within Myself and I don't go
church but I'm still a Christian and I
didn't go to church fan dick I was like
10 or 10 you know what I mean
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible